sky news has discovered that hundreds of
sex offenders are disappearing into our
communities
disguising themselves from detection
through a process that takes
15 minutes online this little girl della
was abused by a man who moved into her
house at that time in the early 1980s
his name was terry price i was always
dancing
and i loved top of the pups and i would
always have my mum had a little record
player that i would
take up to a room and play all the
records and stuff so you'd make it into
a game of
um now you can start stripping off
taking the clothes off to
the music and stuff and i obviously had
no idea what that was
so that's how it started um it just
quickly progressed anyway and it would
be
it was full-on um
right yeah yeah and how were you
six so he raped you when he was six
years old
price was later convicted of raping
someone else and years later della found
the strength to go to the police about
what happened to her
but it turned out terry price had
changed his identity
the officer's saying oh we think
we think we've got terry but he's that's
not his name anymore
so okay so what's his name now
and by that time he changed it to robert
mcewen
robert mcewen was also a convicted sex
offender indeed since abusing dela terry
price changed his name by deed poll
five times committing new offenses with
his new identities
raising the question what's the point of
the sex offenders register
if you can simply become someone else
how many other relationships has he had
how many other jobs has he been able to
get
around children here's how it works
first
complete your application online it only
takes a few minutes
it's advertised as ridiculously simple
to do
keep in mind you'll want them when
changing your name with the dvla
passport office credit card providers
banks and more
the safeguarding alliance put in freedom
of information requests to the 43 police
forces of england and wales about sex
offenders using this deedpole
service to change their names half of
them returned no data
but from those that did there were 1 349
sex offenders who'd notified the
authorities of a name change
but then they asked how many sex
offenders are missing only 16 forces
provided data
but it amounted to more than 900
offenders and many
may have changed their names without
informing authorities
when they change their name by default
they essentially go under the radar of
all authorities
they can obtain a new passport they can
obtain a new driving licence
and essentially they can erase their
past the safeguarding alliance asked the
disclosure and barring service how they
guard against this
they replied the dbs does not undertake
any background checks
regarding applicants changing their name
by deed poll
so what then about laws put in place to
allow people to check on the history of
people you don't know
either working with children or a new
boyfriend moving into your house
class law sarah's law you realise that
they're actually redundant now
if you go and ask is joe blog's got
history no he hasn't because his name
was
dave jones yesterday it makes a complete
mockery of the legal system
it it makes a complete mockery of
everything and actually it renders
the law completely redundant mp robert
halfon wants this debated in parliament
but got this answer
crucially the failure of a sex offender
to tell police of a name change within
three days is a criminal offence with a
maximum prison sentence of five years
so although it may be easy for people to
change their name it is illegal and the
penalty
is quite severe the the crux of the
matter is is that the onus lies
on the offender to tell the truth and in
actual matter of fact it's a far lesser
sentence
for a failure to notify than it is for
the crimes that they're committing
we've found dozens of cases where the
names have changed but the offenders and
their crimes have been the same
manipulative by nature della's attacker
even changed his name again
to disrupt her trial she found out from
her liaison officer
she phoned me on the afternoon and said
oh he hasn't been able to enter a play
i was like what what do you mean like
it's all set up
watch me said he's changed his name so
he'd filled out
the form online deepold changed his name
and now he can't enter a plea yeah so
it's just disrupting
the process he can't enter a plea
because they've asked
they're putting the charges to him and
it's not his name
anymore now called mr mack he was
eventually convicted
the home office has told us it's working
with the courts and dbs to ensure
measures are strengthened
and continuously reviewed in order to
protect the public
victims say the answer is simple don't
allow sex offenders
to change their names jason farrell sky
news